[Music]
okay
i have a story here of this crew
that were they have been on an island
since late february
in the the northern part of the
archipelago
archipelago thank you archipelago in
hawaii
hawaii
uh call like this atoll did i say all
right
i don't know they didn't if they said it
in metal gear that i know if they didn't
then i don't know
my references are simple yeah so they
were on this this like a toll
and so they were there since late
february and since
february put that in metal gear
but what happened yeah so they have been
there this whole time
throughout this whole these four people
this island crew wait they've been
casted away for an entire year uh
since about february late february well
what part of hawaii
i just said the northern part the arc
an archipelago island
say it right again so i can remember the
archipelago and the alaskan fox
archipelago
but which island it's called kurek
keurig yeah then not keurig k-u-r-e you
tell me how you do
that oh i don't know okay you already
can we just call it gilligan's island i
never heard of that island
because it's on archipelago of tiny
i don't know but it says that this is
the only
our part of the archipelago that is
managed by the states
and it's under the jurisdiction of the
federal government and so
they had these four people um like
marine biologists people like
just people that are trained to a
professor
a skipper and the rest
yeah so they their primary job was to
remove invasive plants
and replacing them with native species
and cleaning up the debris and they're
still doing that
sting nets and plastic that washes the
shore and they go there twice a year
one in the summer one in the winter yeah
and so but
what's an invasive plant i don't know
plants that they brought in from a while
back before they knew about this [ __ ]
and then pace the the nature's been
[ __ ] up right
so then uh that's why this crew they go
there
so like they went there in the winter
and then and then they stay there
throughout the summer and then they just
came back
and so during this entire time they
didn't have
direct access to internet that much like
it was a little bit like they got
some like satellite text messages and a
few emails here and there
also like off the grid off off the grid
yeah off the grid
and and so they were able to receive
information but it was like trickling in
a little bit of information throughout
this entire
time so like practically all of 2020
they've
been just getting little tiny bits of
pieces of info oh tell them to stay off
the news
yeah that's pretty fun yeah like one of
the girls like um
she ended up going from she volunteered
from new zealand and she was look really
looking forward to
going onto the summer program beca or
like this program thing
because she wanted to just get away from
the news get away from her phone like
it's like
[ __ ] this let me go let me just escape a
little bit go help
mother nature you know mother nature's
like [ __ ] sometimes though
yeah so then these are the people
and two of them are like their partners
like together like they love each other
yeah they love each other which i don't
remember who
she's from new zealand yeah awkward
these two that are together i could be
wrong sorry but i think it's these two
that they are and like she's the leader
of the
of the crew the body language maybe and
and yeah so they're just talking about
they're being interviewed and
and talking about their experience being
in reintroduced
to society because now they came back
covet is that an indian band
like i said they do covers what is that
like they were aware of what was
happening but like they just hadn't
experienced it themselves they didn't
realize
how [ __ ] up it was yeah and so
here's some photos so it's like some of
the work they do
thank you for cleaning up the trash in
paradise
yeah those are those japanese fishes it
looks like they're digging up coral
like living in this like hot uh yeah
that's a lot of birds
yeah there's a lot of birds so here it
is when they
came back now they have to go i was like
if there's just four people over there
you don't really need a mask i don't
think well yeah there was no coconut but
if they're
here but there were a lot of trains they
were robbing but they didn't know stupid
they didn't know that that stupid so
they did know that cobit was like a
thing because you know in february
it was like slowly like creeping over
here like we we were all aware
but we're just laughing at china well
that was like january oh yeah and then
we're like
china it's coming and we're like wait
wait wait wait
america's not immune we were like in
february we were all like
we'll get a fake doctor and try to talk
about it in february we're like
[ __ ] chinese over there sick damn
thank god we're not sick exactly yeah
march was where really [ __ ] was like we
were all sick this shit's this shit's
for real
yeah yeah all right so i'm gonna play a
little clip of this crew
talking about their experience what
that's crazy
and and it was at a time where we we
didn't have it nobody nearby really had
it
we're just seeing stories on the
television and that sort of thing
don't touch anything get your cottage be
safe you know
and i think that was before there were
cases here but yeah february 26th
yeah we're just finding out that maybe
stuff is starting to creep a little
closer to where we are and
but you know we're off we're leaving it
wasn't really a big concern for us
we just didn't really know i guess i
didn't really know what to think because
we were getting
so many different answers to questions
that we're
asking and they were all different
they're like what's actually going on
out there that's true we're still
feeling that well
every month yeah i got an email from my
sister
and she she used the word pandemic
and i was kind of thought to myself huh
maybe we need to look that up
our field teams go out there to remove
some of the invasive pest species and to
help restore
the native plant habitat it's an
important
that bird's not even flying
yet but as far as i know
everyone's doing that verb okay
pretty big
yeah that's beautiful oh this'll blow
over by the time we get back
i'm like surely it'll be it'll be a old
story
i haven't seen much yet we've been in
quarantine so
one thing that i did see out the window
was some children
playing with masks on that felt totally
apocalyptic that was really weird to see
but yeah it was pretty much just seeing
the children and people on the news
wearing masks that was so weird
wow does it feel normal to you guys now
seeing people with masks or does it
does it still feel not at all it feels
normal to me for me it does normally me
too
because i i don't go anywhere it's only
i only really leave my house to
go to here like to come here and i don't
wear masks all the time so
if i do just so happen to go to the
grocery store or something
and then i see everyone wearing a mask
i'm like whoa it's [ __ ] weird
or when i go to my orthodontist
appointment i'm like this is weird
nothing makes me sadder than seeing
somebody driving alone with the mask on
yeah did they forget i'm like bro no i
do that with the windows down
um just because i think i look cool in
my mask i just feel like
everybody's a doctor you walk around
you're like there's so many doctors
everywhere
or like everyone's ninjas yeah it's so
cool
no but i i when i do go grocery shopping
or like one of my costco and i see
everybody with masks i'm like yeah this
feels this is this is this is this is
everyday now
even when there's no pandemic i hope
people keep wearing masks me too low-key
yeah yeah when they're sick it's like
[ __ ] mask it up [ __ ]
well and and it takes away the
awkwardness of like
when you make eye contact with somebody
i hate doing this but also that's the
only face i know how to make
so it's like but i don't wanna it feels
awkward
but like you know under the mask we just
all kind of like acknowledge that
maybe we're smiling under there so you
make your eye movements more
significantly larger so then that way
they know exactly yeah so this is
covered up and i'm like
smiling at you well i think for me it's
always like the
stop like i always do that yeah what a
gangster
well it's just like i grew up with that
she didn't
the thing i love about the masks is that
small talk is eradicated
just like the flu by the way uh there's
no more small talk and there's no more
flu
which i love about corona i know right
by
now they're already talking about hey
get your flu shot and then get ready for
a flu season
and um are you looking at they haven't
talked about the flu once
there's no flu anymore because we're all
doing such a great job of wearing our
mouths they're throwing the flu
statistics inside the coronas
what that's ridiculous maybe we're all
just sanitized now so no one's getting
sick anymore yeah they're only getting
sick with one thing and it's called
corona
oh obvious well the vaccine's coming
oh true but you know what to be fair i
usually get like pretty sick
during the winter time um like sometimes
like sneezy coffee something back my
throat but like i think
since i haven't been really out anywhere
or really touching anybody i haven't
i've been so healthy this year you get
sick every year
around the winter time really yeah i get
a little like uh
like sore throat itchy well your wife
got chicken box that's true
chill over there that's very true thank
you very much he's a chosen one and he
still gets sick
exactly he's chosen to get sick the
chosen one wouldn't get sick
ever i haven't gotten sick in a while i
take vitamins
if you were really the chosen one you
would never have gotten sick in your
whole life you're not neo
i have to get super sick one more time
to unlock all my powers that are hidden
oh [ __ ] the movies i didn't know the
prophecy because you didn't they're
dormant right now
are you dumb i asked you what the
prophecy was and you didn't die i can't
tell you what else is going
true idiot sorry
no but that that that idea or not idea
but
the fact that this entire year i have
also been
what he said because i don't want to say
cuz i don't wanna jinx it about my
body you know yeah being
good i don't wanna jinx it it's not you
feel healthy you're bragging though
you're bragging a little bit
a little bit of bragging showboating not
doing it i feel extremely healthy
i'm not doing that but but yes
i'm going to be jinxing it you'll be
manifesting it
yeah so what's this more powerful one
see i i just [ __ ] blind myself every
day and tell
the world huh i don't want to mess with
it with
like drinking jinxing anything and i
have already been manifesting it
so i'm just going to continue that and
not say anything to jinx it
i say everything to
this disillusion myself i'm the kind of
guy that'll get cancer i'm like no i
don't i'm suck
i'm so [ __ ] healthy and then it goes
away i'm down i'm down for that
yeah wearing that hat you do look like
you're disillusioned
yeah bye keep del rose